now let's practice what you have learned
here you have several points to remember
the practice requires you to pay
attention to details that you went over
in the previous parts
first the live console allows you to try
running code
the first assignment is to simply check
the code syntax
notice that if you just run what's
already written it will not work because
the syntax is broken
the challenge is to fix the code by
adding small changes that will make it
work refer to the previous section to
make sure that you understand how the
code should be written you will get a
message that the code worked correctly
once you resolve the small issues in the
code syntax
once the code is working and your data
is loaded
try to apply what you have learned about
calling data rows and columns you can
always check the console for output
what you see on the screen will show you
what you are expected to find
in this practice
once you have understood how to write
and execute the code you will find a
link to a jupyter notebook you can use
this notebook as a starting point for
writing a more complete notebook on
loading and exploring different types of
data sets so when you see this kind of
an image that says github collab
interactive notebook you can just click
on that image to get access to this
notebook
once you have completed this part of the
assignment you can save it on your
google drive and use it later when you
need to load a data set
now let's try a new data set
this data set offers a view of gene
expression data it has samples called by
subtype of breast cancer and rows
corresponding to genes here they're just
named gene 1 2 3 etc
once you can technically load and view
the data
let's understand what this data set
actually represents
so a typical
gene expression table as you can see
here is the result of an rna-seq
processing pipeline
what this pipeline does is typically
take unstructured data which was
unorganized and collection of random
reads in a text file also called called
fastq or fasta was mapped onto the
genome to produce accurate numbers that
represent the quantity of each
type of gene so what you see are
sample names and the rows represents
genes
and here you can see the expression
level which is a number that could be
normalized for different types of things
that we will discuss in a different
lesson
we have two specific courses that can
help you understand in detail the full
process one of them is called
transcriptomics and the other one is a
project called modeling cancer precision
medicine in that project you will see
the exact definition of the data set
that we're going to be using in this
practice